in a lot of neighborhoods the public
park is the center of the community
and the basketball court is the center
of that public park
oftentimes these courts are in rough
shape
and there's courts where either there's
no lines or where there's large gaps and
cracks in the court surface there can be
huge dips that would be unsafe hazardous
to play on
so seeing all these courts across the
city inspired me to renovate public
outdoor basketball courts and
collaborate with artists to create
unique works of art for the surface
[Music]
i pretty much played at this court my
whole life
it was a no-brainer for me like i jumped
at the opportunity to be able to come
down and help paint and give back to the
community
[Music]
lincoln park is a special court for me
because i actually used to play here
when i was in school
all my siblings grew up playing on this
court and so this court's been a long
time coming
the actual process of renovating the
court typically takes about two weeks
and usually i'll hire a local
contracting crew to do any crack fill or
patch repair
and then after they're done that we come
in once the court has been resurfaced to
get the artwork down and be ready for
lines
[Music]
since starting project backboard three
and a half years ago we've worked on
over two dozen courts around the world
one of the most fun parts is working
with community volunteers on the court
painting we're gonna start at the tape
line
and we're gonna work our way backwards
you know the basketball court for me was
always a place where
you learned to be an engaged citizen
it's where you met your neighbors and
kind of got together for a common
purpose and i think too often people
think of basketball courts as a nuisance
when really it is a spot that can really
bring people and communities together
[Music]
before this there was
cracks all over the court graffiti
everywhere definitely bad shape
giving back to the community kind of
speaks to me because this is my first
time kind of being involved in a project
like this and it definitely inspires
other kids due to the fact you know the
younger generation always looks up to
the older generation they see you giving
back or inspire them to give back
[Music]
being able to step on a new renovated
court is pretty dope you know it seems
small just a basketball court but you
know it's a lot more than that everyone
comes out people get off work got people
who don't even live in newark show who
come over here to watch the game so
definitely just the little things helps
out it's a lot
this didn't start as an art project it
didn't start as a way to bring art into
parks but i think i recognized that it's
really important for me to inspire and
help others do this in their own
communities you know i want people to
feel like i can make a difference in my
community maybe i'm not painting an
entire basketball court maybe i'm just
buying new nets and hanging them when
they fall down maybe i'm just picking up
the trash you know whatever it is it's
if you care about your park you care
about your basketball court take care of
it
you